everywhere you look these democrats who
so arrogantly pompously claim they
understood governance and would make
washington work properly who for years
told us trump was illegitimate and that
they'd uphold democratic norms who
bleated till they were blue in the face
about trump's cruelty and said they'd
bring compassion these democrats biden
harris pelosi schumer just look at them
now their agenda imploding their
policies failing their humanitarian
crises multiplying
it is all falling apart incompetent
illegitimate inhuman the exact opposite
of everything they pretended to be
everything they touch turns to crap
trump handed them a strong effective
vaccine in record time they screwed it
up with chaos over boosters and their
insane anti-science imbecilities about
protecting the already vaccinated
trump handed them a strong economy
energy independence low tax less
regulation pro growth now look runaway
inflation unfilled vacancies are
collapsing recovery and of course the
most egregious failures of them all
afghanistan which biden had the nerve to
try and spin as a win at the un general
assembly this week
and as we close this period of
relentless war
we're opening a new era of relentless
diplomacy
of using the power
of our development aid
to invest in new ways of lifting people
up
around the world
of renewing and defending democracy
relentless diplomacy lifting people up
tell that to the thousands of americans
and allies stranded behind enemy lines
renewing and defending democracy tell
that to the girls kicked out of school
the women kicked out of jobs all the
afghans who as the taliban announced
this week
will now have their hands sawn off in
public thanks to biden's calamitous
pig-headed insistence on running away
just so he could say by september 11th
that he'd ended the war he failed even
at that he didn't end the war he
restarted it as afghanistan becomes a
terror safe haven again relentless
diplomacy lifting people up it is
clueless impulsivity leaving people
behind
as the united states turns our focus
to the priorities and the regions of the
world like the indo-pacific that are
most consequential today and tomorrow
we'll do so with our allies and partners
through cooperation at multilateral
institutions like the united nations
over the last eight months
i prioritized rebuilding our alliances
revitalizing our partnerships we will
not go alone
oh yeah such cooperation with
multilateral institutions that you've
got the germans saying biden caused the
worst crisis in the history of nato
rebuilding our alliances so well that
our oldest ally recalled their
ambassador revitalizing our partnerships
he can't even remember their names
i want to thank
that fellow down under
thank you very much pal appreciate it mr
prime minister
how does that guy end up as our
president it is just unbelievable
look at the total catastrophe he's
created at the border a massive
humanitarian crisis all because he
wanted to rile up his party's far left
base lying about the reason sending
kamala harris to pathetically pretend
she's going to fix the root causes when
everyone can see the root cause it's
biden reversing trump's policies and
opening the border
even as
they tour the tv studios touting their
great success in clearing the disgrace
of del rio
they're admitting that most of the
migrants are just released into america
what message does that send to all the
people from around the world doing the
right thing and trying to become
americans the right way the proper way
biden talks about decency this is the
opposite of decency instead of an
orderly system it is a chaotic
free-for-all that empowers criminals and
smugglers
and with all these failures all this
incompetence will there ever be
any accountability
well at last we got an answer to that
question this week
yes there will be accountability biden
promised it
it's outrageous i promise you those
people will pay
finally people will pay
but who exactly
will pay
will general mackenzie head of centcom
pay
for saying to the taliban you know what
it's okay we don't need to control all
of car but we'll just keep the airport
will it be the genius who mistook water
canisters for bombs and sent the drone
that killed 10 innocent civilians will
that person pay
will blink and pay for failing to get
thousands of our afghan allies the
paperwork they need and then saying he's
doing everything he can to get them out
will milly pay
for undermining the constitution and the
chain of command for spending the past
year puffing up his own image instead of
preparing for a proper withdrawal for
conspiring with the chinese regime will
anyone pay for the chaos at the border
the screw-up over vaccines the return of
inflation any of it
no
that's not who biden was talking about
the people who are going to pay the only
people in this entire crew of
incompetent muppets the only people who
are actually going to face any
consequences
are border officials that biden's own
open border policies put in an
impossible position they will face the
full weight of accountability for not
riding their horses the way biden wants
them to
that is the single solitary thing that
biden and harris and all the rest of
them seem to be worked up about the only
thing
going wrong in our entire government
apparently what a joke what a total
mockery of accountability
but it's not just the incompetence
there's no legitimacy behind their
agenda look what they're trying to push
through congress the largest tax
increase in history the biggest ever
expansion of the federal government
bureaucracy rules regulations
initiatives programs armies of busy
bodies interfering in every aspect of
your life biden ran as a moderate
centrist he explicitly said he wasn't a
socialist
they failed to win a majority in the
senate they even lost seats in the house
so they barely have a majority there but
they're acting like there's some
socialist party that won in a landslide
pushing a five trillion dollar scheme to
turn america into a centralized european
style welfare state it is illegitimate
and undermines democracy
on top of all this
is the cruelty
they say biden's compassionate
the president also sheds tears when he
tells stories
and it's one of the beautiful things
about him is the compassion
where were biden's tears for the
soldiers whose deaths he caused in kabul
where were biden's tears for the aid
worker he took out with a drone strike
for the seven children killed just to
try and make biden look tough where were
his tears for the babies being passed
over barbed wire by parents desperate to
save them where were his tears for the
toddlers dropped like sacks of potatoes
over the border where were his tears for
the terrified children abandoned by
coyotes in a country completely foreign
to them
i've been asking myself why has it all
fallen apart so quickly we've seen
democrat presidents before we can
disagree with many of the things they
did and said but it wasn't like this
it wasn't an utter shambles a complete
humiliation for the country
and i think i found the answer this week
in that united nations speech i looked
it up on the white house website it's
worth doing actually because you
suddenly realize what we're dealing with
in this biden regime
it's embarrassing enough that this the
greatest nation in the world was
represented to the world
by a bumbling old fool who can barely
string two sentences together but the
content my god i've never seen anything
like it just a string of facile slogans
and vapid cliches saying nothing
conveying nothing just a whole bunch of
nothing
i'm not saying every leader should speak
like demosthenes to be taken seriously
trump certainly didn't but he had
something to say
and no one was ever in any doubt what he
wanted to do and why
biden
there's nothing there
and the people around him aren't good
enough to fill the hollowness
that's why it's all falling apart
biden is nothing
nothing but an utterly mediocre machine
politician surrounded by amateurs hacks
and juvenile leftists
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else